on Prime crime when's the last time you
saw her
nice
characteristics
a woman disappears seemingly Into Thin
Air I have a gut feeling right here when
my son died
a spotlight on the husband I hope you
guys know that I love my wife and I
would never hurt her but is her death
exactly as it seems we were chasing a
ghost essentially you know we're looking
for a needle in the haystack
foreign
[Music]
everybody I'm Jesse Weber and welcome to
Prime crime this is where we break down
the most high profile and memorable True
Crime cases missing person stories are
some of the most chilling ones to cover
but there are times when finding the
body doesn't give you all the answers
it's late May 2020 in the Columbus Ohio
suburb of Westerville husband Matthew
Moore and his wife Emily Noble are
spending the Memorial Day weekend
together they decided to celebrate
Emily's 52nd birthday they went into
Uptown Westerville you had a few drinks
it seemed to be just a normal
uh interaction between husband and wife
there really was a lot of joy that they
had together a lot of walks a lot of
foraging the couple returned home and a
seemingly simple holiday weekend and
birthday celebration
evolve into something else my wife Emily
Noble Roy roofwood has been missing all
day when Moore wakes up Emily is nowhere
to be found you guys have any kind of
fight or anything
has she been depressed no we usually had
a great day yesterday it was your
birthday and we went out when you woke
up in the middle of the night though she
was still there I don't know I'm gonna
say yes everything was so normal when
police arrive at the condo they begin
the search and start asking questions so
no updates whatsoever haven't heard
anything seen anything like that it was
just a very unique case for us that we
we really didn't know where exactly to
start but we knew that we had to to get
on it immediately because obviously that
the clock is working against us at that
point
she doesn't have any history of any kind
of mental illness depression anything
like that she's just looking at the
other girl she gets moody this is just
not her she look at this she never
disappeared for not an offer absolutely
no it just seems to be very different
that someone either
left
unexpectedly or
left from the residence and didn't know
that they were leaving
another officer with a body camera
arrives to help in the search but
Moore's Behavior starts becoming
suspicious
got the feeling right here right here
when my son died
you gotta think it's not like he's a
professional actor it's not like he's
been in the same situation before this
is the first time he's speaking to
police about his wife possibly being
missing more then brings up a theory
suicide man I would I don't know I my
son committed suicide your son committed
suicide
Emily's life much like mats was riddled
with trauma her husband in 2011 her
first husband had killed himself and 17
her brother-in-law committed suicide we
know then Joey Matt's child and her
stepson hung himself it's not like she
had repeatedly attempted suicide and
there was a well-known documented
history of this in Matt's own words this
was so unlike her she doesn't do this
and then for him to come out with a
statement it just makes no sense she was
the burger so like there was something
along those lines
do they try to hide it do they go like a
long ways away or something or it
depends at the time of this this case he
was still very much grieving from the
loss of his own son who had killed
himself in in July the prior year as he
speaks with law enforcement Moore starts
referencing things that may not look
right let me show you one thing okay
just because I'm crazy no show me this
thing's here
doesn't belong here what do you mean it
doesn't belong here it doesn't belong
s
right there
I took it and put it there
the one thing that struck me was that he
brought attention that the core the
electrical cord and something in the
garage was out of place that he's the
one who pointed to Sergeant to that
location there is a chance to hurt me
people do do that none of us prepare for
traumatic situations we're never going
to be able to really control our
reactions it's literally like Japan
and it's just not early I don't
understand why someone wouldn't take
their wallet wouldn't take Keys anything
else a cell phone there was just no
personal belongings of hers that left
the condo that morning coming up more is
brought in for further questioning but
where is Emily I hope you guys know that
I love my wife and I would never hurt
her
foreign
[Music]
because your neighbors are out there
saying it was in the last two weeks
would that be correct I don't know in
the spring of 2020 Ohio woman Emily
Noble disappeared Without a Trace just a
day after going out to celebrate her
birthday with her husband Matthew Moore
when authorities find no signs of where
she might be they set their sights on
more I want to help you out I want to
get this going up because I didn't do it
and I want you to find whatever it all
happened to her I didn't do it that's
the line that sticks out to me the most
what didn't you do because at that point
all we knew was that Emily disappeared
nobody had made any sort of accusations
to him and yet he's already
coming up with these defenses that I
didn't do it and he's talking as if
she's already dead I've gone through
this in my head
with the timeline and some of my times
don't line up I made a phone call when I
thought I was sleeping okay just know
that the times are going to be might be
wrong and I would hate to give you a
wrong time and then be like suspect me
or something he started trying to cover
up a little bit be like look my times
may be off time has passed I just don't
want you to use that against me
[Music]
if someone is like Diane what time did
you drink that protein smoothie this
morning after you worked out
just know that I drank it after I worked
out I do not know the exact minute that
I consumed it add trauma to that right
when things are happening at a speed
with which you can't relate because
you've never experienced that type of
trauma before I I don't think he was
inconsistent you guys hung out and
talked we hung out in the kitchen and we
got really long really super well it's
your birthday we started making out and
we went into the bedroom and yeah thanks
a cell phone data was pretty amazing
abruptly in the evening for a period of
almost three and a half hours neither
phone is in use there's not even a
evidence that either phone was activated
and then from that point on
essentially all night long you can see
all sorts of cell phone behavior on
Matt's phone where he's on YouTube and
he's on Facebook and he's sending out
text messages and he's looking up
various stories I fell asleep and uh I
woke up to urinate
I had a few text messages I might have
posted on Facebook
I I don't know
texted my stepfather there's just
essentially
non-stop behavior on his device from
approximately 1 30 in the morning until
about the time that he calls the
Westerville police
so between 11 and 3 what were you doing
it was lying in my son's room okay I'm
just kind of just chilling recovering it
seemed odd to me that
he would just kind of go about his his
normal behavior and talk with friends
and family and there was never any
mention that oh hey by the way I woke up
and Emily isn't around did you post
something to her Facebook account to her
friends on Facebook like hey she's
missing
I didn't until later on when it was told
to me
that it was was as serious as it was it
wasn't like it was after the I just
showed up I just need to know if you did
it and there's nothing wrong with it I
don't I can't I don't know Matt this was
two days ago
up next is more telling the whole truth
there was a a roller coaster
relationship but it wasn't like anything
that was anything you would think that
someone would hurt someone over
[Music]
I mean at times you'd say I didn't want
to be married to anymore because it
doesn't go down the lines that I'm
sitting in a police station Arena in the
spring of 2020 52 year old Ohio woman
Emily Noble vanished with no signs of
kidnapping or Where She Went
investigators take a closer look at her
husband Matthew Moore Moore claimed that
when he woke up she was just gone this
came the day after the two spent a night
out together drinking and celebrating
Emily's birthday while speaking with
police investigators confront more about
the couple's relationship is there a
chance that she went out at some point
in some abductor from Westerville what
are the odds that happened almost zero
for zero I know I did not hurt
investigators seem to believe there was
something missing from Moore's story
literally two weeks ago she
there was one person that she kind of
confided in through text messages and
she said Matt picked another fight with
me last night this is heavy
Matt picked a fight with me yesterday
and said some awful things I'm not
wearing my wedding ring
that doesn't sound like somebody who's
in a happy relationship as things
progress it seems to be a lot more of
this up and down roller coaster where
one minute it's I love you and I love
you too will you acknowledge you've got
some pretty heavy when your wife says
I'm took up my wedding ring I don't
think we're going to stay together it's
not as heavy as you think it is there
are other text messages where it's
I'm not wearing my wedding ring anymore
and you said something that broke me
and I'm going to be single by summer and
then they would get right back to a
normal loving relationship and it just
kind of seesaw back and forth like that
over months you guys are really going to
try to I'm not trying to do anything I'm
I'm reading your wife's words I think if
we were to to look at our text messages
with our partner all of us we would you
know probably win some of the things
that we say you know when you read a
relationship via text message again
perceptions aren't necessarily reality
guys I did not hurt myself I did not
perfect I loved you I would speculate to
say that she might have hurt herself
when he makes reference to her it's in a
past tense you know I loved her you know
past tense it's not this oh I actively
love her it's all I used to she loved me
I really just didn't think it was a big
deal I don't know how all of us are
gonna feel if our son has just killed
himself and now our wife is missing 10
months later but I'm probably not at my
best why would you think she would hurt
herself because she was not that she
ever would I'm just saying she she was
emotional on his initial 9-1-1 call he
states that she's not suicidal there
were no problems but then during the
interview with Detectives
he makes a very specific statement
not only does he think that it's suicide
but he thinks that she would hang
herself that's not a comment that any
spouse is going to say when there's no
history no evidence of it whatsoever
Moore's questionable Behavior would
continue after he left that
interrogation room because he allegedly
didn't seem all that interested in
finding Emily why is he not out actively
beating the bushes day and night trying
to find her why is he not doing anything
he should be looking day and night for
his wife itself when he couldn't be
bothered to even leave the condo
couldn't be bothered to pick up the
phone and get updates he wasn't
uncontrollably sobbing you know he
wasn't uh constantly out there pounding
every single door he was grieving and
searching in his own way Matt is
actually an introvert and the truth is
is that Matt did participate in searches
he just didn't do like the massive group
searches with law enforcement because
Matt was at least smart enough to know
that he was the suspect but Moore says
something very curious in his interview
with investigators if she were to hang
herself where would she do
do it where you where it should be
easily found
and that would prove to be especially
chilling four months later when Emily
Noble's remains would be found her body
hanging in the woods with a USB cord
wrapped around her neck just a half a
mile away from the couple's condo once
Emily's remains were found I still never
got a phone call asking what happened he
couldn't even be interested into what
her cause of death was that just screams
that there's nothing but the fact that
it's a homicide and that Matt Moore was
directly involved put your hands back on
your head
do not move yes sir in June 2021 Moore
is arrested and charged for murder with
authorities believing he staged the
scene to look like a suicide
just listen to what you're being told
when we would look at Matt he would not
provide any reason for us to rule him
out there's no Westerville Strangler who
is hanging out in the woods who has this
motivation to make a homicide look like
a suicide the only one who has that
motivation is Matt Moore we're gonna
walk over here towards the gray when we
return Matthew Moore stands trial for
murder but did he kill his wife there's
no evidence
to the scene
[Music]
since she hasn't been easily found is it
plausible that she didn't kill herself
you
in the fall of 2020 the remains of 52
year old Emily Noble are found in a
wooded area near the Ohio home she
shared with her husband Matthew Moore
four months after she disappeared her
husband now charged with murder for
allegedly staging her death to look like
a suicide in August 2022 two years later
more goes on trial Emily Noble did not
die of an incomplete hanging the cause
of death of Emily Noble was a manual
strangulation I thought it was a
winnable case from the very beginning
when he talks
in his interview what would Emily do
well
she's going to the woods and hang
herself what a lucky guess the evidence
that would have honed in on is exactly
the evidence that the prosecutor honed
in on it's not about whether Emily
killed herself or whether Emily didn't
kill herself and someone else did really
it's that Matt didn't do it the evidence
will show no motives members of the jury
the evidence will show that the state's
Theory
is based on speculation and inferences
you don't have the Smoking Gun in a case
like this you know there's no
confession you don't have videotape of
it going on you know blood evidence no
bullet holes in the wall the only
physical evidence that we have is Emily
herself the state presented evidence of
Moore's questionable behavior during the
investigation including Eerie comments
he made to police and a seeming lack of
interest in the search for Emily however
it was the medical evidence that proved
particularly crucial
form and opinion as to the cause and
manner of death and death of Emily Noble
it was highly unlikely that it was
suicide the amount of trauma that would
have to happen to occur to cause the
fractures and death
um
would have to be inflicted but the
defense presented a unique witness for
the jury an expert to determine if it
was possible Emily could have hung
herself and we started by just hanging
that female small female crash test
dummy to make sure the branch suspended
dummy was the branch able to sustain in
those five tests the branch did not fail
so I would say it's the same defense I
thought The Narrative of she couldn't
have possibly hung herself was really
refuted when you saw the visual of the
dummy dropping and the branch doesn't
break like for me it was powerful
when it came to the prosecution they
themselves had a few different moments
like a tense exchange with the judge
yeah I'm sorry but I would object you're
going forward anyway right now without
the elected counting prosecutor who's on
this case but she chose not to be here
I'm not going to participate in this
proceeding without the elected County
prosecutor I think this is a shame that
you're going forward well I'll tell you
what if you want to be here for the
decision that's your business well your
honor I think this is outrageous you're
going forward without the process
every day they were losing and they
hated it and his walking out of the
courtroom I believe was a symptom of
that or how in their closing argument
they did something curious ladies and
gentlemen I submit to you that's an
opportunity at that time for him to go
leave the house
and go confront her in the woods the
closing argument of the prosecutor for
the first time ever saying that Matthew
Moore followed her into the woods that
very same night strangled her and then
just made it seem like a suicide wait
wait wait hold up you had a whole trial
to talk about that because then that in
the opening you never said that the jury
was finally sent back for deliberations
at the conclusion of the case and just
three hours later Matthew Moore would
learn his fate verdict on count one
we the jury find the defendant Matthew L
Moore not guilty of murder as he stands
charged verdict on count two we the jury
find the defendant Matthew L Moore not
guilty of murder as he stands charged in
count two of the indictment verdict on
count three we the jury find the
defendant Matthew Moore not guilty of
felony's assault as he stands charged it
was incredible you know it felt good
just did you know I went back and I had
such a privilege of talking to the jury
in this case some of them thought Emily
did kill herself and some of them
thought there was someone else who was
responsible but either way where they
said they unanimously quickly landed was
that Matt didn't do it I respect their
decision however I believe that the the
verdict is incorrect if we didn't feel
that we had a strong enough case for a
homicide it never would have been
presented to the courts Mr Moore I think
from day one everyone's wanted Justice
for your wife Emily and I've heard that
phrase a lot and I think everyone truly
desires that
but I think the jury has also said
Justice family is not Injustice for you
and you are free to go
I told Matt what I tell any of my
clients that are acquitted and have a
second chance is really make the most of
it right and start to live every day day
by day it's not a marathon because
really recovering from the trauma of
just being wrongfully incarcerated
you know I I don't know how someone ever
kind of gets to a place of normalcy
again after that
a jury decided that the prosecution did
improve Matthew Moore murdered his wife
yet the death of Emily Noble remains
incredibly eerie and we may have to
accept the fact that we might never know
what actually happened
that's all we have for you here on Prime
crime as always thank you for joining us
and until next time stay safe
foreign
[Music]